o Olá pessoal aqui quem fala é o Dark É
sou eu coloquei dois vídeos vocês tiram
tiram tiram ver não sei não sei o que é
que se passa a destruir o pessoal do
vídeo vai ser quando é que eles gostam
vamos assistir a mais um som presta eu
já fiz um vídeo neste ano o link na
descrição foi um filme de terror mas vai
ser bem figura este vai ser basicamente
uma compilação decisões que nós não
vimos tipo no dia a dia e pelo caixas de
fósforos aspiradores secador de cabelo
coisas assim que isso vai ser tudo em 3
dias portanto pessoal sabe peguem nos
auscultadores coloca em cima Aumente o
volume e isso comigo estes 131
em 3 2 1 pé
e o
o choque é uma caixa de fósforos também
não posso para quem não ouvi direito aí
Aumente o volume falar muito volume
e o que que ela vai fazer agora o que eu
faço para esquerda e
e você pode fazer base para o rosto aqui
no ouvido
e o Caio tá muito barulho não sai
fósforo e
a tarsis linda olha aí para o Google tá
bom Agora a caixa
o rádio Ele parece mesmo se vontade o
meu lado agora está nesse lado aqui
agora está aí para aqui ó só parou parou
parou e o preço aqui em vista que andar
às voltas
e por outra vez
E aí
já tá bem Já percebi para de grãos
próximo 1
e agora o tiro fotos lá para o fundo
fita cola e por isso vai muita cola para
colar cabeça e fita-cola tudo é um
e o parou parou parou parou por quê
e eu tava cortar o cabelo então a cortar
o cabelo meu estado é real pessoalmente
volumes não conseguem ouvir bem Aumente
o volume
e falou que para aqui atrás Tabu é real
tá muito longe 1
Oi oi tá contar muito já corta menos
E tu tá onde agora agora não consigo
escrever eu não consigo entender onde é
que ele tá agora se casar ai agora que
eu fiz o corte agora está a ficar primo
não tá deixa lado agora aqui agora está
aqui eu já não sei eu não tenho para o
confronto com o cabelo para para para
para para a tá muito perto já é
e tu tentar perceber o que é que ele
está a fazer eu sou o saco lá para fora
né Oi estou bem não precisa de mensagem
também eu sei que eu estou bem tudo aí e
tu estás bem tu estás agora é
e acabou três mas não ainda não tem
saída meu anjo estou na rua estou na rua
estou na cidade não estou em cidades tem
o campo tudo sobre abelha
e aqui agora aberto aqui ó é uma velha é
uma mosca ou um mosquito houve um vídeo
incerto qualquer
e vamos que uma mosca no ouvido olha
p*** po tu tens que experimentar isto tu
tens que ela parece que entrou no ouvido
no ouvido dentro porque ela parece que
entrou lá que tu sente cima uma podem
entrar Play On
o preço do é que medo não estivesse
muito mesmo
Você já parou já parou eu não sei se
isso é uma mosca se é uma vez parece
surto Parece mesmo é
Oi Rute
a porta aqui desse lado agora
Ah tá lá o fundo tá lá o fundo ela ela
tá se afastar está se afastam carai Já
está perto mim tá aqui tá aqui tá aqui é
que tá bem vontade de matar a mosca
abelha acho que é velha
e olha aí ela só foi embora já foi
embora
o meu Este foi brutal este som foi
brutal é que parecia mesmo que a água
dentro dentro no ouvido
e olha o outro outro ok temos um Riacho
que eles na água sob a água já tem uma
cascata
E aí
eu não percebi que não sei que ago
México
bom dia para alguém com uma mangueira
assim acho que é uma mangueira c****** é
uma tempestade é uma tempestade por
favor não pessoal fica mais altas cargas
e
oi oi tô aqui agora pô é que sábio
completo dublado 1
é muito igual perturbada ou não parece
bem ó
E aí
se alguém aqui correr atrás nós
olá uh uh
é tão barco não navio eu já não quis a
minha é muito misturado
Oi para o sindágua acabou o pessoal que
eu vou suas três dias foi muito brutal
meu foi muito ótimo meu o das abelhas
está Espetacular que tá bué fixe anda
cobre outras vantagens ouvir isso eu vou
te por Abelha e disse-me sócios Não
esqueci não é bacana Ok há uma parte em
que parece que ela entra no teu ouvido
sentido é a pressão tipo lá eu tenho
fobia a insectos Foi por isso aperta bem
também vai sentir a para entrar no teu
ouvido juro falei
e o contenção
Oi Paula a
E aí ainda não é eu não tenho aqui só
que nojo nojo nojo para mim
bom então vai vontade de tocar no ouvido
Oi Rose Maria Caracas foi embora não ela
tá me mas tipo não é uma parte que
parece que ela entrou entrou Vingança e
hoje para morrer aqui então imagina lá o
tipo nós estamos a dormir depois aquele
mosquito e agora Pessoal espero que
vocês tenham gostado de terror eu já não
consigo encontrar mais nenhum assim um
que seja bom para fazer um vídeo
Portanto vocês souberem de algo mandei
aí pra vocês tenham gostado quando que
eu posso like fiquem bem e até a próxima